[Music]
so far we've seen the various changes
that occur in an adolescent in this
video we will be discussing about an
important concept of how secondary
sexual character wait a second do we
know what exactly these secondary sexual
character
secondary sexual character they are
characters that are exclusive to the
individual sex of a person and are not
primary what does the statement meet by
the way by the word sex I mean the sex
of the individual male or female by not
primary I mean the characters which are
not required for the process of
reproduction that's why we call them
secondary in boys for instance there is
a growth of beard have you ever seen
girls having a long or trimmed beard of
course not
however it is an exclusive character of
males which is not found in females so
this is the simplest example to
understand the concept of secondary
sexual character let us understand the
concept with another example in case of
females one extremely important physical
change during puberty is the enlargement
of breasts it is exclusively found in
adolescent females so are there any
other set of secondary sexual character
in males and females yes of course apart
from the growth of facial hair the
growth of hair on the chest under the
arms and in the pubic region are other
examples of secondary sexual character
similarly in females
apart from rest development hair growth
around the pubic region and under the
arms is also seen so in a nutshell the
secondary sexual character
are those characters which are not
really required as a part of
reproductive system but do you know what
exactly makes these secondary sexual
character doing pure bertie these
characters are all thanks to the
hormones secreted by the gonads yes
hormones are the most important player
in this process the male gonads called
testes secrete the male sex hormone
called a testosterone
this is responsible for not only the
development of the reproductive tissues
but also for the development of the
secondary sexual character in males and
the same is applicable to the female sex
hormone called the estrogen secreted by
the ovaries it brings about the
development of female reproductive
tissues at the same time it takes up the
responsibility of developing the
secondary sexual character in the female
individuals who do you think controls
the activities of these hormones in our
body the hormones regulate several
processes but who regulates the
secretion of these hormones exactly the
master mind to control all the hormonal
secretions is the gland called the
pituitary gland next we will talk about
these hormones their major roles and how
to bring about all the necessary
activities inside a body
[Music]